for the first time wind and solar have  produced more energy in the united  states than nuclear power and this is  very very interesting now i've said  before  i'm okay with new nuclear as a bridge to  completely sustainable and renewable  energy  which will take a little bit of time to  build up to some of the people who are  reflectively against nuclear power are  against it on the basis of 50 year old  nuclear technology if we were to build  new nuclear power  a lot of the safety and other concerns  really would would not be an issue  that being said my concern would be if  we get hooked on new nuclear which takes  years to come online are we going to  delay  increasing solar and wind these numbers  are interesting because they show that  those solar and wind numbers are already  going up and if we double or even triple  down there right now we might be able to  increase those as sources of energy  much more quickly than many people might  think